ce matin nous recevons monsieur Sylvain
vaserman candidat proposé par le
Président de la République pour occuper
les fonctions de président du conseil
d'administration de l'ADEME et ce en
application de l'article 13 de la
Constitution
comme vous le savez cette nomination ne
peut intervenir qu'après l'audition de
la personne pressenti devant les
commissions compétentes de l'Assemblée
nationale et du Sénat
audition qui doivent être suivies d'un
vote je rappelle que cette nomination ne
pourra intervenir si l'addition des
votes négatifs de chaque commission
représentait au moins les 3/5 des
suffrages exprimés dans les deux
commissions
cette commission est publique cette
commission est ouverte à la presse et
retransmis sur le site du Sénat
à l'issue nous procéderons au vote à
bulletin secret
je rappelle qu'il ne peut y avoir de
délégation de vote et que le
dépouillement doit être effectué
effectuer simultanément à l'Assemblée
nationale et au Sénat
à cet égard je tiens à vous préciser que
l'Assemblée nationale a déjà procédé à
votre audition la semaine passée sans
attendre je vais passer la parole à
notre rapporteur Martin de Sidrac qui va
conduire cette audition vous pourrez
ensuite nous présenter votre candidature
et nous faire part de vos motivations
avant de répondre aux premières
questions de la rapporteur puis mes
collègues sénateurs vous interrogeront à
leur tour pour une séquence de questions
réponses je vous remercie et sans plus
attendre je donne la parole à Martin de
Sidra rapporteur
merci monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues monsieur Wasserman nous allons
examiner ce matin les forces et
faiblesses de votre candidature avec la
rigueur requise par cet exercice mais
sans a priori je vous proposerai de
répondre à des questions de deux ordres
d'une part votre vision de la transition
écologique et votre rapport au
territoire et d'autre part la manière
dont vous envisagez votre éventuelle
président de la dame
commençons par votre vision de la
transition écologique et votre rapport
au territoire il faut le reconnaître
monsieur vacerman la transition
écologique n'est manifestement pas au
cœur de votre parcours professionnel ou
politique on peut certes noter votre
passage en tant que directeur général de
gaz de Strasbourg entre 2009 et 2017
mais cela suffira-t-il à construire une
vision systémique et transversale des
problématiques environnementales
j'ai eu à nouveau cette impression à la
lecture de votre ouvrage chronique du
perchoir que vous avez rédigé en 2020
quand vous étiez vice-président de
l'Assemblée nationale et sur lequel je
me suis appuyée pour préparer cet
entretien
il faut se projeter à la fin de votre
ouvrage passe page
20090a 294 pour enfin en savoir un peu
plus sur votre vision de la transition
écologique vous y prenez un
développement durable positif tout en
estimant quand la matière de grande
rupture sont nécessaires vous dites je
vous cite que les jeunes générations ne
nous pardonnerait pas notre inaction et
qu'il faut savoir trancher quitte à
interdire plutôt qu'à inciter
dans le même temps vous estimez en
matière de transition énergétique que la
rupture consisterait à accepter que ces
transitions soient territoriales et que
cette rupture s'appuie sur un élan
citoyen mobilisateur ce n'est pas
inintéressant mais cela me laisse un
tout petit peu sur ma forme monsieur
Wasserman peut-être pourriez-vous nous
apporter plus de détails sur votre
vision de la transition écologique en
nous précisant par exemple auquel les
quatre scénarios de la dame pour
atteindre la neutralité carbone en 2050
vous vous référez
concernant votre rapport au territoire
les choses me semblent un peu plus
claires votre expérience de mère de quoi
dezenheim village du Bas-Rhin donc de
moins de 1000 habitants si je ne me
trompe nous donne des gages quant à
votre capacité à percevoir la réalité de
terrain pour les élus locaux dans votre
ouvrage vous vous montrez également plus
prolixe quant à votre égard votre regard
pardon sur l'organisation territoriale
de nos politiques publiques vous y
défendez une décentralisation à la
française fondée sur la différenciation
en évoquant les travaux législatifs
ayant conduit à la création de la
Communauté européenne d'Alsace vous y
décrivez le rôle du maire comme un
catalyseur d'engagement citoyen au
regard de ces éléments j'imagine que
vous portez un regard favorable à
certaines évolutions décentralisatrices
apportées par la loi 3DS
le législateur a en effet souhaité mieux
associer les établissements publics de
coopération intercommunale à fiscalité
propre à la gouvernance de l'ADEME il a
également prévu la délégation d'une
partie des fonds chaleurs et économie
circulaire géré par l'ADEME aux régions
volontaires ayant conclu avec l'agence
une convention de transition énergétique
régionale
souhaitez-vous renforcer plus encore les
relations et collaborations entre
l'ADEME et les collectivités
territoriales en particulier avec le duo
région intercommunalité
après vous avoir interrogé sur votre
vision de la transition écologique et
votre rapport au territoire j'aimerais à
présent que vous nous présentiez la
manière dont vous envisagez la
présidence de l'opérateur à laquelle
vous êtes aujourd'hui candidat
naturellement les questions que je vous
poserai ce matin seront très proches de
celles que j'ai posé à votre
prédécesseur monsieur Ravignon il y a
quelques mois
commençons par les moyens de l'ADEME je
rappelle que le budget de l'ADEM fluctué
lors de la précédente décennie entre 500
millions d'euros et un milliard d'euros
il atteint en 2023 un niveau record de
4,2 milliards d'euros je constate
toutefois que les moyens humains n'ont
pas suivi dans les mêmes proportions les
effectifs ont certes augmenté en 2023
avec la création de 90 postes
supplémentaires mais il faut prendre un
peu de recul en 2022 les moyens humains
de l'ADEME étaient en réalité inférieure
à ce que l'agence a connu sur une bonne
partie de la décennie précédente
on sait par ailleurs que le
fonctionnement de la dame se caractérise
par un recours significatif à de
l'intérim ou des contrats à durée
déterminée
cette situation n'est pas durable alors
même que les politiques menées par
l'ADEME demandent un suivi au long cours
nous vous attendons donc au tournant
concernant le schéma d'emploi de l'ADEME
en espérant que vous pourrez nous
partager ce matin des éléments
rassurants sur ce point-là
deuxième point d'attention le
positionnement de la dame au sein des
institutions oeuvrant en matière de
transition écologique comment
comptez-vous articuler vos compétences
avec celles d'autres opérateurs de
l'État qui interviennent dans des champs
proches du vôtre je pense évidemment au
serema concernant l'adaptation au
changement climatique
l'efficacité de l'action publique
implique d’éviter les redondances voir
les logiques de concurrence entre
opérateurs publics qui doivent tous
pousser dans la même direction
troisième point d'attention la
gouvernance de l'ADEME profondément
impactée par la récente adoption de la
loi 3DS cette loi attribue en effet ou
préfet de région la fonction de délégué
territoriale de la dame le préfet de
région représentera localement
l'établissement et dictera à la tension
du représentant territorial de
l'établissement des directives d'action
territoriales et participera à
l'évaluation du responsable territorial
de l'établissement si on peut comprendre
la volonté d'un contrôle de l'État sur
un établissement dont l'importance croit
d'année en année cette évolution ne doit
pas se traduire par une main mise de
Paris sur l'action territoriale de
l'ADEME monsieur vasserman pouvez-vous
nous donner des garanties quant à
l'autonomie de l'établissement dont vous
briguez la présidence vis-à-vis de
l'État
je vous remercie pour votre écoute et
vous laisse nous apporter des éléments
de réponse à ses premiers
questionnements je vous remercie merci
votre candidature est de répondre aux
questions de la rapporteur merci
je vous remercie monsieur le Président
Madame la rapporteur mesdames et
messieurs mesdames laissez matrices
messieurs les sénateurs
j'aimerais commencer d'abord vous
remercier pour votre temps à évaluer ma
candidature j'aimerais commencer par
partager avec vous ce que je crois dans
mon parcours et pertinent au regard de
la responsabilité à laquelle je postule
évidemment mon parcours des Luc local 10
ans mère de village c'est effectivement
800 personnes à côté de sonhime
président d'un petit PCI la communauté
de communes de lakerlande puis
vice-président d'un plus grand EPCI
après fusion
et élu régional j'étais pendant deux ans
en charge de du SRDEI
ce parcours des lieux local me semble
indispensable parce que beaucoup des
enjeux de l'ADEME sont territoriaux j'y
reviendrai dans un instant réponse à vos
à vos interrogations madame rapporteur
deuxième point de mon parcours
l'entreprise
l'ADEME a le monde économique comme
interlocuteur je vous rappelle que les
subventions qu'elle donne pour un réseau
de chaleur par exemple sont à
destination des entreprises avec un
dialogue sur leur business plan leur
rentabilité comment la subvention
s'intègre dans tout cela il faut à mon
sens avoir une certaine lecture des
éléments du monde économique troisième
point
évidemment mon expérience de
parlementaire qui me permet de
comprendre un peu plus les rouages de la
décision publique et l'importance
d'apporter des éléments pour vos
décisions chacun est à sa juste place et
la dame comme vous le disiez de façon
indépendante de vendre éclairer la
décision publique que ce soit au niveau
national et local j'y reviendrai dans un
instant également
et le dernier point la direction
générale pendant 8 ans d'une entreprise
publique locale c'est une société
d'économique de la ville de Strasbourg
qui s'appelle réseau GDS réseau gaz de
Strasbourg j'aimerais souligner que
lorsque je suis arrivé dans cette
entreprise elle faisait du gaz naturel
depuis 150 ans quand j'en suis parti
30% du chiffre d'affaires et aujourd'hui
50%. était sur des thématiques
directement liées à la transition
énergétique et à l'ADEME notamment avec
des réseaux de chaleur avec du
biométhane on a été le premier site à
injecter du biométhane à partir des
stations d'épuration dans les réseaux de
gaz
et des contrats de performance
énergétique donc 30% de l'activité du
chiffre d'affaires ça a été une
véritable évolution de ce modèle et
c'est à ce moment là que j'ai découvert
sur le terrain combien le rôle de
l'ADEME était décisif parce qu'aucun de
ces projets n'aurait aboutissent en
l'ADEME donc j'ai pu d'un point de vue
très concret en tant qu'opérateur
économique certes ceci d'économique donc
dans le dans le domaine public mais
mesurer le rôle déterminant de l'ADEME
et j'aimerais aborder la première des
convictions alors madame la rapporteur
merci beaucoup d'avoir lu mon ouvrage on
est écrit 5 en fait et je me permettrai
de dire que celui-là qui traite
effectivement de ma vision du perchoir
n'aborde pas pleinement des sujets que
j'aborde dans deux autres ouvrages
d'abord celui qui s'appelle le monde
d'après commence demain matin écrit en
2020 à la sortie de la crise du covid
pour voir comment et quels sont les
décisions que je suggérais à l'époque et
surtout celui-là qui est peut-être ma
conviction numéro 1 sur le sujet la plus
pertinente c'est un livre blanc dont
j'ai écrit chacun des mots en 2016 qui
s'appelle le modèle territorial
l'énergie un accélérateur de la
transition énergétique et qui explique
ma vision de la transition énergétique
territoriale j'ai la conviction que les
cadres que vous votez à Paris le cadre
général que vous votez à Paris et bien
sûr déterminant mais que les projets
d'énergie renouvelables la transition
énergétique elle réussit ou elle échoue
elle naît sur les territoires
est-ce que les élus et les acteurs
économiques arrivent à créer une
dynamique est-ce que les citoyens ont
une acceptabilité des projets qui sont
portés c'est bien les territoires qui
vont faire que la transition énergétique
réussira ou échouera et ça je l'ai
exprimé donc dans dans ce livre blanc
que que je crois qui n'est pas donc une
conviction nouvelle ça date de 2016 mais
que j'y crois qui est fondatrice en tout
cas dans la candidature que je porte
aujourd'hui
vous m'interrogez sur le rôle de l'ADEME
sur la vision
territoriale sur sur les moyens je
voudrais dire avec beaucoup d'humilité
que
ceux qui peuvent construire la
feuille de route de la dame pour les 5
ans à venir c'est pas quelqu'un comme
moi qui est une vision encore extérieur
qui n'est pas encore dialoguée avec les
partenaires sociaux dialoguer avec de
l'intérieur de la dame et c'est pour
cela que si vous choisissez si vous me
faites confiance la première chose que
je ferai c'est un tour des régions pour
aller voir trois types d'acteurs qui me
semblent fondament fondamental à
rencontrer d'abord bien sûr les acteurs
du territoire les élus locaux qui soient
régionaux qu'ils soient les
représentants des EPCI ou des
associations d'élus
deuxièmement les préfets qui ont un rôle
déterminant notamment depuis la loi 3DS
et troisième point bien sûr les équipes
de l'ADEME pourquoi et pourquoi je
prends cet engagement de boucler ce Tour
de France avant disons fin septembre au
mi-octobre en fonction des agendas je
pense cet engagement parce que nous
avons
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans une une
période où l'ADEME devra négocier un
contrat d'objectif et de performance
avant la fin de l'année
comment pouvoir si vous me choisissez en
tant que président de l'ADEME négocier
travailler sur un contrat de performance
sans écouter les acteurs les parties
prenantes dans les territoires que ce
soit ses élus qui travaillent au
quotidien avec la dame que ce soit les
préfets que ce soit les équipes donc je
commencerai par cela parce que
l'actualité fait que je dois le faire
dans une période très resserrée si vous
me confiez cette mission pour pouvoir
alimenter les sujets de la feuille de
route et donc du contrat d'objectif et
de performance que la dame devra devra
négocier
j'aimerais partager même si je ne peux
pas évidemment aujourd'hui m'engager sur
une feuille de route j'aimerais partager
trois convictions fortes que je pense il
faut mettre sur la table dans dans cette
logique du rôle de l'ADEME la première
je crois qu'il faut beaucoup travailler
sur ce que j'appelle personnellement
l'efficacité carbone de l'euro investi
finalement tout ça c'est de l'argent
public et tout ça ça a une cause la
transition énergétique du territoire
et je crois que cette traduction dans
l'efficacité carbone
de l'argent public qu'on investit au
travers de la dame
et déterminant et que ça doit être un
étalon notre action pour mesurer que ce
soit des résultats court terme ou des
résultats moyen terme mais pour mesurer
l'efficacité de cette action et c'est la
moindre des choses qu'on doit aux
décideurs publics qui allouent des
moyens vous l'avez dit Madame la
rapporteur très important que de rendre
compte de l'efficacité carbone de ces
investissements on pourra y revenir si
vous le souhaitez
le deuxième point majeur
concerne la dimension territoriale et là
il y a deux points ou trois points que
j'aimerais souligner
le premier concerne la coordination des
acteurs madame la rapporteur vous
m'interrogiez sur le sujet effectivement
entre le serema la NCT j'ajouterai
peut-être la banque des territoires
l'ADEME bien sûr il y a une pluralité
d'acteurs qui ont finalement une unicité
d'objectifs sur la transition
énergétique du territoire
j'ai appelé deux personnes dans les
dernières semaines
qui sont le directeur général délégué de
l'ADEME pour l'interroger parce que
j'avais été surpris à l'époque de voir
beaucoup de gens dans des réunions sans
bien comprendre à l'époque qui faisait
quoi
et j'ai appelé j'ai appelé également le
directeur général adjoint du serema par
une relation commune pour leur dire
voilà moi je pense qu'il y a un sujet
est-ce que vous partagez cette vision
ils m'ont dit oui et j'ai découvert par
exemple alors certains
dans cette logique là me parle de
convention bien sûr mais j'ai découvert
qu'il n'y a pas de réunion structurée et
de points entre les patrons de ces
activités régionaux tous les mois tous
les trimestres j'en sais rien pour voir
les besoins du territoire notamment en
accompagnement d'ingénierie pour les
collectivités faire le point sur ça
faire le point des ressources de tous
ces bras armés de la puissance publique
et pouvoir optimiser les solutions
qu'ils apportent donc je crois que ça
commence par le dialogue de ces femmes
et de ses hommes qui dirigent ces
régions et mon engagement si vous me
confiez cette mission c'est de commencer
et j'espère main dans la main avec les
différents acteurs à
missionner chacun des directeurs
régionaux pour avoir ces points de
coordination c'est le minimum moi je
crois plus d'abord au dialogue de
terrain entre les patrons locaux dans
chacun des territoires
en prise directe avec leur territoire
pour remonter optimiser voire comment
optimiser la réponse de l'État
deuxième point sur l'ingénierie à
apporter auprès des collectivités
territoriales
je me suis dit avant de venir ici je
vais faire une je vais faire une petite
recherche internet sur ce que le maire
que j'ai été ou le président comme que
j'ai été quand il efface à évidemment
l'intention de travailler sur la
transition énergétique quels sont les
acteurs clés qu'il doit contacter et les
mécanismes qu'il doit maîtriser
alors ça tient sur une feuille je vais
peut-être pas tout vous lire parce que
le temps mais mes contraintes mais ça
passe de l'agence locale d'énergie du
climat les conseiller en énergie
partagée les économes de flux qui sont
financés par un programme acte plus les
fonds verts les dispositifs les
générateurs le programme territoire
engagé transition écologique les
contrats de chaleur renouvelables
blessés ou tes contraintes bien sûr les
CRT au contrat de réussite des
dimensions de de la transition
écologique l'été à CCT bref beaucoup de
dispositifs qui sont importants en soi
et je ne fais pas un jugement de valeur
sur ces dispositifs bien sûr
comprenez-moi bien mais qu'il faut
décrypter il y a des élus j'étais encore
ce week-end avec un élu vice-président
d'une communauté de communes en Alsace
qui savait que j'étais candidaté pour
cette mission il me dit moi tu sais je
dois je dois je dois travailler sur la
transition énergétique on a missionné un
bureau d'études déjà pour comprendre
parce qu'en fait comme j'ai pas déjà
d'ingénierie quand il y a un dispositif
j'en profite pas j'en dispose pas je ne
le connais même pas
et on a cette logique de décryptage qui
est essentielle donc c'est pas un
jugement de valeur sur chacun des
dispositifs ou chacun des acteurs c'est
le décryptage indispensable et là-dessus
l'idée que je que j'aimerais proposer je
sais pas si elle aboutira si elle est
pertinente mais l'idée que j'aimerais
proposer
c'est que dans chacune des communes et
des EPCI de France il y a un
correspondant Adam un élu j'entends bien
un élu il y a déjà 700 postes je crois
qu'ils sont cofinancés par l'ADEME dans
les territoires mais je dis bien un élu
qui puisse être qui puisse constituer un
réseau d'élus qui accepte d'investir un
peu de son temps
sur des formations initiales sur une
mise en réseau sur ce décryptage
évidemment ça prend un peu de temps mais
qui accepterait d'être le relais
privilégié des réseaux que
territorialement par région pourrait
animer pour essayer d'apporter cette
expertise ses clés de lecture et se
décryptage aux élus de terrain au sein
des conseils municipaux au sein des
conseils communautaires donc je pense
que c'est important parce qu'il ne faut
pas laisser s'essuyer de transition
écologique uniquement en métropole qui
bien sûr ont l'ingénierie et ont des
enjeux majeurs sur sur des réseaux de
chaleur mais il faut arriver à apporter
ses clés de lecture au plus près du
terrain à mon sens et je vais vous en
donner un exemple vous avez voté à une
très très large majorité assemblée Sénat
quasi uneanimité une proposition de loi
déterminante il y a deux mois
c'est celle qui permet aux collectivités
qui donnent un atout de plus aux
collectivités c'est de faire des
contrats de performance énergétiques
donc globalement c'est quoi l'idée
générale c'est la synthétie la
schématise mais globalement un tiers
investisseur va financer la rénovation
de d'un certain nombre de bâtiments et
se rembourser financer tout ça avec les
économies d'énergie que ça générera donc
plutôt que d'avoir un budget de
fonctionnement en énergie en dépense
d'énergie parce que parce que je
rappelle le chantier du siècle 400 fois
40 millions de mètres carrés à rénover
rapidement à court terme à rénover ou
décarbonée pour les collectivités un
enjeu colossal cet outil de contrat de
performance énergétique j'en ai vécu un
puisque j'ai piloté le deuxième CPE dans
la région d'Alsace sur 900 logements
dans le quartier du Virel lorsque
j'étais lorsque j'ai monté cette
activité au sein de réseau GDS
ça nécessite une ingénierie précise ça
nécessite des cahiers des charges
standards fait par un tiers de confiance
et même les maîtrises d'ouvrages à
l'époque je doute que je pense que c'est
encore le cas aujourd'hui n'était pas à
même d'accompagner suffisamment les
petites collectivités sur la définition
et la mise en œuvre de ce genre de
projet l'ADEME à mon sens c'est un
exemple sur lequel l'ingénierie
l'expertise au service des territoires
est indispensable parce que c'est
compliqué parce que la transition
énergétique parce que l'ancien contrat
de performance énergétique faut-il le
faire au niveau de la commune faut-il le
faire avec une taille critique un peu
plus importante au niveau de l'EPCI et
si on le fait quelle est la
prévisibilité qu'on demande à
l'opérateur économique qu'est-ce qu'on
lui fait porter comme quoi sur la
gestion du risque est-ce que c'est sur
les comportements et sur les
consommations est-ce que c'est sur le
prix de l'énergie comment on articule
tout ça c'est compliqué je l'ai vécu en
tant cette fois-ci que que capteur
économique à l'époque il mettait en
œuvre je suis persuadé que c'est un
exemple très précis qui reprend une
proposition de loi que vous avez votée
et qui est absolument ma EUR à mon sens
mais qu'il faut accompagner sur le
territoire sinon ce sera un problème
parce qu'on arrivera pas à utiliser à à
bon escient cet outil qui est un outil
puissant mais qu'il faut savoir
maîtriser
dans cette logique
j'aimerais arriver peut-être un
troisième point qui me semble important
il me semble qu'il y a un chaînon
manquant sur les territoires entre
l'ADEME et les parlementaires beaucoup
des parlementaires qui m'ont avec qui
j'ai échangé ne connaissent pas leur
directeur de la dame et je pense que
c'est la moindre des choses que lorsque
vous vous votez des budgets si
conséquents sur la transition
énergétique et à l'ADEME vous puissiez
mesurer concrètement sur vos territoires
comment ces budgets que vous votez à
Paris se traduisent dans la réalité des
faits et je m'engage là c'est un
engagement clair si vous me confiez
cette mission à ce que chaque année les
directeurs régionaux rendent compte en
invitant spécifiquement les
parlementaires du territoire rendre
compte de la façon dont ces budgets sont
utilisés et de leur vision sur
l'évolution de l'ingénierie et des
besoins d'ingénierie des territoires je
pense que c'est un c'est un point
important
j'aimerais peut-être conclure par deux
points extrêmement importants que vous
avez mentionné madame la rapporteur le
premier sur les moyens alors je n'ai
évidemment pas encore interagit avec les
représentants du personnel c'est dans ma
vie j'ai souvent eu évidemment en tant
que dirigeant d'entreprise des des
dialogues importants avec les
représentants du personnel ni avec les
parties prenantes des territoires et je
le disais le tour des régions est un
point essentiel
mais je sais et beaucoup mon remonté en
fait spontanément ce sujet de
d'adéquation des ressources et des
moyens donc je ne peux pas apporter de
garantie bien sûr puisque c'est pas moi
qui décide un plafond d'emploi mais je
voudrais simplement dire et vous en êtes
conscient mais je voudrais le redire que
ce qui constitue la force de l'ADEME
c'est avant tout l'expertise incroyable
des femmes et des hommes qui travaillent
je vous le reconnaissez ils sont
internationalement reconnus le modèle de
l'ADEME est un modèle qui est très
souvent envié et toujours respecté pour
l'expertise qu'il apporte et la mission
de la dame je parlais tout à l'heure de
la façon d'éclairer la décision publique
c'est pas de prendre parti sur l'un ou
l'autre point chacun doit être à sa
juste place la mission de l'ADEME telle
que je la perçois elle est double
d'abord d'éclairer la décision publique
d'être un tiers de confiance qui vous
fournira à vous à l'exécutif au ministre
au parlementaire les éléments de
décision les les instructions de
différents scénarios qui vous
permettront de prendre les bonnes
décisions il y a des sujets aujourd'hui
sur le plastique qui crée des débats
importants faut-il des consignes ou pas
le rôle de l'ADEME n'est pas de savoir
si son président pense AOB le rôle de
l'ADEME est d'être le tiers de confiance
qui va éclairer la décision publique
pour que vous puissiez prendre votre
décision
avec un jugement éclairé
libre évidemment vous êtes libre mais
non faussé en tout cas avec ce que je
crois et des en tout cas ce que je pense
est essentiel des études les plus
objectives les plus fiables les plus
sûrs en provenance de l'ADEME
deuxième point sur ma vision je sais que
j'arrive à la au terme de mon de mes 10
minutes monsieur le Président
le rôle de de déploiement des solutions
existantes je crois qu'il y a un message
d'action et un message d'espoir que je
voudrais porter
énormément de solutions existent le rôle
de l'ADEME c'est d'être l'accélérateur
qui va généraliser massivement les
solutions qui marchent
et aider à éclore à expérimenter les
solutions nouvelles je crois que là on a
un rôle opérationnel de l'ADEME qui est
d'être ce bras armé déploiement des
solutions qui fonctionnent je prends un
exemple j'ai changé avec beaucoup de
responsable de filière sur la géothermie
de surface il y a certains pays sont
beaucoup plus avancés que nous on a
probablement un rôle de travail avec la
filière chez nous en France c'est la
filière forage qui pose question mais en
tout cas lorsqu'une Région souhaite
déployer massivement ce type de solution
lorsque des EPCI soient différents
appels à l'ADEME de travailler avec la
filière pour pouvoir viser un
déploiement rapide et massif ce qui
compte c'est l'efficacité carbone de
l'euro investie comme je le disais tout
à l'heure et la vitesse d'exécution
parce qu'évidemment il y a urgence voilà
j'aimerais terminer sur sur ce message
d'action et d'espoir j'espère avoir
répondu madame la rapporteur à la fois à
vos sujets aux interrogations sur les
moyens sur mes convictions notamment la
conviction en matière de transition
énergétique
et écologique
sur le rôle des préfets je crois que
c'est vraiment avec les les dialogues
que je pourrais construire dans les tous
premières semaines si vous me confiez
cette cette mission en tout cas vous
aurez je crois compris ma mon humilité
par rapport à ce sujet qui est un sujet
majeur mais ma très grande détermination
pour les les exigences responsabilités
auxquelles je postule je vous remercie
pour votre attention
merci Monsieur candidat je vais donc
donner la parole à mes collègues j'ai
donné la parole à Madame Bonnefoy
merci monsieur le président madame le
rapporteur mes chers collègues monsieur
vaserman une tribune du journal du Monde
paru au mois de mai appelée à la
nomination
urgente d'un président de l'ADEME
celle-ci détaillait les compétences
attendues pour piloter l'agence cite le
président de la dame devra sincèrement
être convaincu formé et informer des
enjeux écologiques qu'il attendent dans
tous les cas elle devra porter une
vision et impulser une dynamique forte
pour le développement des projets en
lien avec les collectivités locales et
les entreprises partout sur le
territoire et être entièrement consacré
à cette tâche la proposition de votre
candidature à la présidence de l'ADEME
semble mieux convenir aux besoins de
l'agence notre exécutif semble avoir
entendu et cette tribune et le souhait
des parlementaires d'avoir un président
entièrement dévolu à la transition cette
vacances n'a que trop duré au regard des
enjeux d'adaptation encore relevés par
le dernier rapport du Haut Conseil sur
le climat présenter vendredi dernier qui
nous appelle la doubler le rythme de
réduction des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre et à prendre un bras le corps
la question des puits de carbone qui ont
malheureusement réduit leur absorption
de CO2 de l'ordre de 20% entre 2020 et
2021 fin 2021 l'ADEME a effectué
l'important travail prospectif sur
l'atteinte de l'objectif de neutralité
carbone en 2050 en présentant plusieurs
scénarios cette étude soulignée
l'impérieuse nécessité d'une
planification orchestrée des
transformations associées en l'état les
territoires les acteurs économiques et
les citoyens depuis le gouvernement
c'est doté d'un secrétaire général à la
planification écologique en charge de
l'élaboration des stratégies nationales
comment voyez-vous la bonne
complémentarité entre l'ADEME et la
nouvelle instance du CGPE par ailleurs
la dame fait figure de référence pour
les collectivités vous l'avez rappelé en
matière de transition écologique
l'agence constitue partenaires
fondamental pour l'ingénierie de la
transition et vous l'avez rappelé les
élus locaux sont aujourd'hui un peu
déconcertés vous l'avez dit aussi face à
toutes ces propositions d'ingénierie le
gouvernement a créé de la confusion dans
des structures qui fonctionnaient bien
ainsi quel est vous y avez répondu en
partie votre vision de l'articulation
entre l'ADEME la NCT le cerema et l'état
des concentrés les préfectures
départementales et régionales l'annonce
d'un guichet partenariat unique à
destination des collectivités des
acteurs économiques est une bonne chose
pour les accompagner dans leur
expérimentation et dans leurs besoins de
financement ce guichet pourrait être
précisé dans la future loi de
programmation énergie climat
pourriez-vous nous préciser votre vision
sur cette évolution des missions de la
dame même si vous y avez en partie déjà
répondu récemment pour ma part j'ai été
nommée au conseil d'administration de
l'ADEME et je m'en réjouis je souhaite
enfin donc vous interroger sur la
question de l'emploi public de l'ADEME
même si vous avez là aussi aborder le
sujet même si quelques postes ont été
créés cette année on constate que les
effectifs sont quasiment constants
depuis 2009 alors que les crédits
pilotés sont de plus en plus importantes
pour pallier ce manque l'ADEME recrute
des intérimaires qui sont en incapacité
de suivre les dossiers sur le long terme
ce qui n'est pas bon pour notre
ingénierie d'État et pour le suivi des
projets des collectivités territoriales
avez-vous conscience de cette
problématique qui nuit à la fois au
travail de nos ingénieurs d'états et aux
politiques publiques et comment
comptez-vous résoudre cette question
durant votre mandat merci pour votre
réponse vos réponses merci avant de
répondre je vous propose qu'il y a
beaucoup de questions je vais donner
encore la parole à 4 de mes collègues
parmi vous répondrez au 5 questions et à
l'issue je ferai une deuxième série de
questions j'ai donné la parole à Madame
prévu
si monsieur le Président merci pour
votre présentation et je crois comme
vous effectivement que des vêtements des
énergies renouvelables doit s'appuyer
sur les territoires le questionnement
que je me pose à ce sujet là puisque
vous avez été maire d'une commune c'est
comment faire puisque vous le savez les
budgets des communes ne permettent pas
toujours de faire ces investissements
mais moi je crois très fortement qu'on
avancera quand ça viendra effectivement
des collectivités comment faire alors
vous avez évoqué des dispositifs qui
permettraient avec comment vous l'avez
appelé un
correspondant Adem qui est peut-être une
bonne solution sur les aides et
l'accompagnement et pour vous rappeler
mais vous le savez sans doute que les
élus se trouvent un petit peu démunis
quand ils veulent engager ce genre de
démarche et ensuite une deuxième
question quel regard portez-vous sur la
gestion des déchets
qui est un très vaste sujet qui est
quelque part un petit peu impensé
puisque le flux ne fait qu'augmenter et
que cela crée bien évidemment des coûts
supplémentaires et pour les citoyens et
pour les collectivités et pour
l'empreinte carbone également sur le
ramassage et quel est votre vision sur
la hiérarchie des trois R qui s'appelle
d'abord réduction puis réemploi puis
recyclage donc voilà je voudrais avoir
votre point de vue sur ce sujet là merci
merci
monsieur le président monsieur Sylvain
ces dernières décennies l'ADEME a déjà
bien changé depuis les origines la seule
maîtrise de l'énergie dans un contexte
de fortes expansion de l'offre
d'électricité nucléaire avec
l'urgence climatique d'aujourd'hui et la
transition écologique qui sont imposées
donc la DM à élargi son périmètre
fusionner les agences préexistantes
qualité de l'air notamment déchets et
fortement augmenter ses capacités
budgétaires au moment où la ou la
massification là la généralisation de
cette transition nécessite de de passer
en quelque sorte de l'époque des
collectivités pionnières à celles de la
généralisation de l'implication des
territoires sachant qu'on veut pas se
permettre des zones blanches de cette
transition écologique comment
envisagez-vous les développements futurs
de l'ADEME est-ce que ça taille est
suffisante est-ce qu'il est pas
nécessaire de vous laver un peu évoqué
de de regrouper des opérateurs publics
un peu éparpillés rapprocher peut-être
l'ADEME et le cerema peut-être aller
vers un opérateur puissant unique de la
transition écologique éclairant et
accompagnant les décisions d'action
publique
ne faut-il pas parallèlement mettre au
niveau la capacité agite agir des
territoires il y a la dotation climat
que prône le Sénat peut être l'émergence
à venir d'une fonction publique
territoriale pour l'ingénierie de la
transition même si de telles décisions
ne relèverait pas de vous bien sûr j'ai
quand même envie de connaître votre
vision de ces perspectives d'avenir
merci je vais donner la parole à
Monsieur devinez
merci monsieur le président
avoir votre point de vue sur deux thèmes
la sobriété et l'économie circulaire sur
il semble que la production des énergies
bocarbones je précise bien renouvelable
et nucléaire ne pourra pas compenser
entièrement celle des énergies fossiles
du moins d'ici 2050 donc il faudra donc
me semble-t-il repenser nos modes de
consommation
selon vous les repenser s'appelle le
terme qu'on a utilisé maintenant c'est
sobriétés selon vous la sobriété
deviendra-t-elle une composante
indispensable pour réussir notre
transition énergétique et écologique et
si oui vers quel secteur doit-elle
s'orienter en priorité et sur l'économie
circulaire qui est une thématique de
l'action de l'ADEME a juste titre car
elle permet de replacer la question de
la ressource au centre des enjeux de
compétitivité d'indépendance et
d'environnement dès lors quels sont les
filières stratégiques à privilégier et
accompagner selon vous pour accélérer le
développement de l'économie circulaire
dans les années à venir
merci je donne la parole Didier modely
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le candidat merci pour votre
présentation même si je
considère que elle était quand même
marquée par le prisme de l'énergie alors
que mais c'est lié aussi à l'historique
l'histoire de la dame et à votre
parcours professionnel mais c'est vrai
que l'émission de l'ADEME sont très très
étendues aujourd'hui qu'elles touchent
bien sûr les collectivités vous avez
fait largement référence mais aussi les
entreprises les associations et les
particuliers et dans des domaines très
très variés jusque au tourisme slow
tourisme etc donc moi j'ai aucun doute
sur votre volonté votre sincérité quant
à la mise en oeuvre de de ce que vous
avez évoqué au sein de la dame y compris
avec les équipes la relation avec les
élus et je voudrais simplement rappeler
alors il se trouve que j'ai été Luère en
2001 et que j'avais cette volonté en
créer de travailler sur ces questions de
façon transversale donc j'avais pas
d'adjoint l'environnement c'était le
maire qui avec son DGS qui gérait
l'essentiel et que je me suis appuyé sur
un outil qui existait à l'époque qui
s'appelait le plan environnement des
collectivités qui étaient proposés par
la dame et je vais partir des quatre
communes de France qui ont mis en œuvre
ce plan environnement des collectivités
avec la dame et si j'en parle c'est pas
simplement pour me rappeler avec
nostalgie ce que j'ai fait mais c'est
surtout parce que quand on parle de la
NCT du Serena et d'un syndrome de
structure je pense que pour les élus
locaux j'ai tendrais même aux
entreprises qui se demandent comment
mettre en oeuvre avec des moyens
quelquefois très simples il s'agissait
d'un référentiel secteur par secteur
activité par activité domaine par
domaine de mise en œuvre la feuille de
route d'une démarche qualité qu'on
retrouve dans les entreprises elle
s'appelle ISO certaines s'appelaient
l'Agenda 21 d'ailleurs pour les grosses
collectivités à l'époque et en fait
c'est simplement écrire faire ce qui est
écrit écrire ce que ce qu'on fait c'est
le principe de base d'une démarche
qualité avec des choses très très
simples et je pense qu'aujourd'hui les
élus locaux qui sont bombardés
d'informations diverses de différentes
structures aurait plus loin de ce de
cette feuille de route de ce cahier des
charges qui permettrait et en plus c'est
très simple ça permet de cocher
simplement ce qui a été fait et de
partager en tout cas avec les équipes au
début ou de des équipes du personnel
donc voilà je voulais simplement relater
ça ça existait par le passé c'est un
très bon outil qu'il faut sans doute
réactualiser et augmenter mais en tout
cas la dame à cette mission vocation
multiple
d’être aussi non pas perçu comme un seul
ou un simple distributeur d'aide au
subventions mais d'être dans
l'accompagnement très en amont auprès de
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens que ce
soit des élus des entreprises ou des
associations
merci pour toutes ces questions je vous
propose de répondre à mes collègues
monsieur le candidat merci je vous
remercie monsieur le Président je vais
répondre point par point si vous le
permettez madame Bonnefoy effectivement
aujourd'hui vous parliez notamment du
rôle du SGPA
le aujourd'hui la différence par rapport
à 5 ans c'est qu'on a des objectifs
chiffrés on sait qu'on produit en France
400 millions de tonnes le carbone et
qu'on doit atteindre en 2030 270
millions je fais à peu près c'est un
tout petit peu plus que 400 donc on a un
plan de marche on a 130 millions de
tonnes de carbone à supprimer de façon
récurrente
et ça ça change tout
parce qu'on peut avoir des approches
beaucoup plus rationnelles et avec le
SGP notamment de travailler sur bon
finalement comment se décomposer 400
millions de tonnes quels sont les
gisements de progrès c'est-à-dire où
est-ce qu'on peut avoir ce que
j'appelais tout à l'heure l'efficacité
carbone de l'euro investi si je mets un
million d'euros dans tel endroit ou dans
tel endroit combien ça va jouer sur les
130 millions et en fait la réalité c'est
que les acteurs doivent se mobiliser sur
cet objectif et qu'on a pour le coup
maintenant une feuille de route claire
on a 130 millions de tonnes à trouver en
7 ans de façon récurrente donc à chaque
fois qu'on crée un réseau de chaleur à
chaque fois qu'on va isoler un bâtiment
à chaque fois qu'une collectivité va
lancer tel ou tel projet on doit réussir
à avoir comment ça contribue à cet
objectif en tout cas en tout cas vous le
soulignez c'est un c'est un changement
majeur et et je crois que c'est ça qui
doit rendre optimiste je disais tout à
l'heure action à espoir à chaque fois
qu'on fait une action il faut pas avoir
le sentiment que c'est une goutte d'eau
dans un océan qui de toute façon nous
non on a un objectif chiffré après on
peut avoir les débats sur est-ce que la
France est 1% etc mais la France a un
pouvoir d'influence majeur dans le monde
et elle ne réussira à l'avoir en matière
de transition écologique que si
elle-même réussit à faire ce chemin là
sur sur son 1% c'est pour ça qu'il est
important c'est important pas de fois
point de vue mathématiques mais dans
l'impact qu'il peut avoir donc
effectivement vous avez raison on a un
objectif chiffré il est géré par la
planification écologique je crois que
c'est une méthode d'approche rigoureuse
d'objectifs à atteindre et c'est ça qui
doit fédérer les acteurs sur la partie
les points que vous évoquiez je pense y
avoir y avoir répondu effectivement sur
le la coordination des acteurs notamment
madame Préville le sur le le budget et
comment faire vous m'interrogez
également sur la gestion des déchets les
flux alors quel est mon expérience dans
le domaine il est d'abord il est d'abord
en tant que président de PCI puisque
alors en Alsace on était dans notre
communauté de moi c'est c'est une
expérience très personnelle enfin on a
mis en place la levée pesée on a vu
quand même 30% de réduction de des
déchets en communauté de communes de
lakerlande corrers belge on était le
vice-président j'étais pas en charge de
cela c'était c'était partager dans notre
Com Com par l'équipe de par le président
et vice-président mais en tout cas cette
ce côté extrêmement concret de la
réduction des déchets je l'ai vécu
simplement d'un point de vue
opérationnel mais j'ai mesuré aussi les
questions qu'on avait avec les citoyens
les débats sur est-ce que pourquoi ça
nous coûte plus cher est-ce que ça va
nous coûter moins cher sur est-ce que
les sacs poubelles vont se retrouver
finalement sur les trottoirs dans la rue
à la place d'être dans les poubelles
bref j'ai vécu ça alors en Alsace on me
dit toujours oui mais c'est l'Alsace bon
donc vous arrivez à faire ça moi je
pourrai pas dans mon territoire moi je
pense que c'est les ai beaucoup d'élus
pilotent ces démarches là en tout cas
j'ai pu mesurer combien ils étaient
efficaces
évidemment l'accompagnement de l'ADEME
sur ces sujets est important je voudrais
souligner on parlait d'énergie et on
parlait de gestion des déchets
j'ai visité assez récemment un
UVA unité de valorisation énergétique
qui à partir des déchets qu'ils brûlent
chauffe donc produit de la chaleur et
l'électricité 90% de chaleur et 10%
d'électricité je vais vous partager une
pensée qui m'a une question que j'ai
posée et une pensée où là je pense la
dame un rôle à jouer
les 10% d'électricité sont produits
alors c'est un contrat avec la
collectivité à un moment où
où ça tombe le mieux on sait depuis cet
hiver tout le monde tous les Français
savent depuis cet hiver que bien sûr la
quantité d'énergie qu'on consomme est
important mais le moment où la consomme
est tout aussi importante parce que
votre machine à laver que vous mettez à
tourner à 23h le soir si on est même en
août qu'une centrale est fermée qui a
pas de vent que les éoliennes tournent
pas etc on peut se retrouver et c'était
le cas en 2022 dans des pics
d'électricité et le pic d'électricité
c'est quoi c'est pas seulement
d'électricité cher c'est aussi que votre
machine à laver elle tourne au charbon
allemand ou au fioul lourd Nord italien
parce qu'on est dans un pic et que la
gestion du pic fait que pendant ces pics
on importe de l'électricité très
carbonée donc on a intérêt à réduire ses
pics et bien je pense que les UVA on
doit travailler et là c'est un rôle
d'optimisateur que sur lequel l'ADEME
pourrait avoir un dialogue avec chacun
des industriels et chacune des
collectivités qui gère ses DSP pour que
l'énergie soit produite et c'est 10%
électricité soit produit au bon moment
et que quand il y a un pic c'est d'abord
le de devoir citoyens de l'acteur
économique et les élus évidemment seront
d'accord pour que ces 10% soient
produits au bon moment aujourd'hui c'est
pas le cas dans beaucoup du vélo de
France donc ça c'est des sujets
d'optimisation qui peuvent paraître
minuscules au regard des grands enjeux
mais en fait ils le sont pas du tout
parce que contribuent à l'effacement
d'un pics d'électricité c'est contribuer
de façon très efficace très efficace à
la diminution des productions de de
l'impact carbone climatique je prenais
cet exemple parce que parce qu'il me
semble montrer les interactions entre
les différents sujets que peut traiter
que peut traiter l'ADEME
sur le sujet monsieur ferrique de du
rapprochement de l'organisation alors
moi je suis pas un grand centralisateur
donc les modèles uniques je sais pas et
toute façon c'est vous qui décidez je le
fais court c'est vous qui décidez et
franchement comme je suis pas dans
l'organisation aujourd'hui je sais pas
quel est le meilleur modèle je ne sais
pas en revanche ce qui est certain c'est
qu'il est inexcusable que la puissance
publique ne s'organise pas territoire
par territoire pour être optimisé il n'y
a pas besoin de convention parisienne
pour ça il n'y a pas besoin de grande
loi il y a d'abord besoin d'un dialogue
opérationnel concret pour savoir voilà
les moyens que j'ai sur le territoire et
je peux me battre pour en avoir plus etc
mais voyant voilà les moyens que j'ai
voilà les expertises que j'ai le cerema
est très fort dans certains domaines la
dame très fort dans d'autres domaines
certains domaines se recoupent bon
comment on organise localement ça c'est
quand même l'intelligence des femmes et
des hommes sur les territoires qui vont
permettre en dialogue avec les élus de
progresser sur le sujet donc
pas encore d'avis tranchée sur est-ce
qu'il faut tout fusionner ou pas je sais
pas si on me demandera à mon avis en
tout cas il sera beaucoup plus éclairé
quand j'aurai parlé avec les parties
prenantes et avec l'ensemble des
partenaires moi je voudrais de façon
très court terme optimiser ses moyens en
local et là je pense que rien ne s'y
oppose et le fait que le préfet une
responsabilité de coordination des
moyens publics des bras armées de la
puissance publique fait que je suis
optimiste sur le fait que par ce
dialogue avec les 13 préfet de région
que j'irai voir avec si bien sûr si le
mouvement leur porte avec avec
ce dialogue avec les les élus et leurs
besoins en termes d'ingénierie
d'accompagnement avec bien sûr le
dialogue avec les équipes
opérationnelles je suis sûr qu'il y a
une un chemin de d'amélioration rapide
efficace sur lequel on
peut se reposer je crois d'abord sur ce
niveau de dialogue au niveau le plus le
plus territorial
monsieur devinez évidemment vous posez
la question extrêmement importante de la
sobriété de l'économie circulaire
et de quel secteur et quel composante
est la plus la plus urgente à aborder il
y a dans le domaine de de
la sobriété des sujets qui concernent
les entreprises je vous ai dit avoir
vécu la transformation d'un modèle
économique avec ces femmes et ses hommes
qui travaillent depuis 150 ans dans le
gaz naturel et qui ont complètement
réorienté réinventé le business model de
cette entreprise je mesure pour avoir
été chef d'entreprise que c'est pas en
claquant des doigts et avec une
injonction extérieure qu'on change ces
modèles là ça prend du temps ça
nécessite beaucoup de volontarisme des
équipes dirigeantes ça nécessite aussi
alors il y a une prise de conscience
massive des acteurs économiques du rôle
qu'ils ont à jouer mais prenons un
exemple très simple la production de
l'hydrogène vous savez que l'industrie
consomme beaucoup d'hydrogène
aujourd'hui il est massivement produit
avec du CH4 du méthane on prend du CH4
on met de l'eau 2 tout ça donne du CO2
donc du carbone et et du H2 l'hydrogène
c'est l'ingénieur qui peut reprendre ses
cours de chimie
il faut absolument qu'on arrive à agir
sur ce levier d'action il y a des
projets européens en la matière
notamment enfin vous avez vu ces projets
d'infrastructures européenne pour
produire du de l'hydrogène bleue et
réussir à l'acheminer à l'endroit de à
l'endroit des consommateurs de
industriels et je crois j'ai interrogé
sur le à l'Assemblée sur le sujet ma
conviction personnelle c'est que chacun
doit faire un tour d'horizon à 360° sur
ces comportements propres qui soient
acteurs économique qui soit acteur
personnel et là bien sûr c'est vous qui
décidez ce qui sera autorisé ce qui
restera interdit ou le mentionné dans
mon ouvrage certains sujets relèvent
l'interdiction et le législateur
interdit ce projet dans le diesel en
2035 dans des sujets sur lequel il y a
de l'interdiction en tout cas
aujourd'hui je crois que la conscience
est elle la prise de conscience est-elle
que c'est déjà à chacun de faire ce
travail là et c'est vous avec j'espère
des études de qui vous permettront de
prendre vos décisions qui pourront
placer le juste curseur entre ce qui est
interdit et ce qui ne l'est pas et entre
j'ai envie de dire cette dynamique que
de toute façon on doit construire chacun
je crois est conscient des enjeux la
dame doit être là le l'accélérateur de
de traduire la conscience des enjeux de
du climat dans la réalité concrète de ce
qu'on peut faire au niveau des
collectivités au niveau des entreprises
notamment je disais à l'assemblée que
c'est pas moi qui vais donner des leçons
de morale à AOB sur ce qu'il doit faire
et comment il doit le faire nous sommes
c'est pas mon rôle et c'est vous qui
trancherez qui mettrez le curseur sur ce
qui est autorisé ce qui ne l'est pas
monsieur mandeli vous vous soulignez
avec à juste titre le sujet du plan
environnemental des collectivités de
cette feuille de route alors j'ai été
bercé dans les modèles qualités
d'entreprise je vois très bien ce que
vous ce que vous voulez dire et la façon
dont la méthode peut servir l'objectif
et je crois que c'est typiquement dans
le réseau de correspondant à thème des
élus vous savez moi j'étais maire de
cottenheim j'avais une administration de
une personne voire une ou une nuit
personne c'est pas elle que j'allais
demander à ma secrétaire de mairie de
d'écrire le plan d'action et le voilà
donc un élu parce que c'était une
personne formidable mais évidemment elle
avait pas la marge de temps pour le
faire et je crois qu'un élu il y a une
richesse dans les conseils municipaux
enfin vous le savez tous dans les
conseils municipaux vous avez des cadres
vous avez des des personnes associatives
vous avez vous avez une richesse et je
suis sûr je suis sûr en tout cas ça
aurait été mon cas si j'avais été maire
que si on me demandait désigner une
personne qui accepterait d'investir un
peu de son temps un élu un peu de son
temps sur ce sujet là pour avoir une
approche rationnelle pour comprendre les
méthodologies comprendre les outils
décrypter les possibilités mais je suis
sûr que c'est un pas important vers
cet accompagnement des collectivités en
tout cas je crois que c'est une idée que
j'aimerais mettre sur la table tester
leur nom tour des régions si vous me
confiez cette responsabilité si vous
choisissez
et je crois que c'est une étape concrète
pour essayer de progresser dans cette
dans cette approche là voilà j'ai essayé
monsieur le Président de répondre aux
questions merci le mieux possible merci
je vais donner la parole à Guillaume
Chevrollier
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
vaserman vous avez été maire et
président de Pessi donc vous connaissez
bien le le terrain vous le savez la mise
en oeuvre des projets dans le cadre de
la transition énergétique
requiert beaucoup de temps et d'énergie
pour les collectivités les élus et aussi
des budgets conséquents quand on voit
vous l'avez évoqué le coût des études de
faisabilité le coût des interventions
des bureaux d'études et puis après le
coût de mise en oeuvre des projets donc
moi comme un certain nombre de collègues
je vais vous interroger sur comment vous
envisagez l'action de l'ADEME pour
accompagner encore davantage ces
collectivités d'un point de vue
informatif et financier afin qu'elle
puisse être comme elle le souhaite
encore plus pleinement engagée dans la
transition énergétique et peut-être pour
préciser encore davantage par rapport à
vos propos c'est quelle mesure très
concrète de simplification
des procédures à la fois pour les études
et pour le financement face à la
complexité croissante et même quand on
parle de digitalisation ça a parfois de
pair avec une complexification pour
remplir les dossiers donc c'est vraiment
ce qui revient du terrain cette
complexité et donc quel plan pour moins
de bureaucratie au sein de l'agence de
l'ADEME qui va être un bras armé
important pour la transition énergétique
ça c'était la première question la
seconde la deuxième la France a fait
l'objet de diverses condamnation
notamment de la Commission européenne
par rapport au non respect de normes
sanitaires sur la qualité de l'air
notamment concernant le dioxyde d'azote
et aussi nos respects relativement sur
les particules fines
qu'est-ce que vous envisagez si vous
êtes demain à la tête de l'ADEME pour
que la France soit conforme aux normes
européennes et que nos concitoyens
respirent un air de qualité et enfin
pour terminer vous avez parlé de
développement durable positif et donc
derrière ça qu'est-ce que vous mettez
comme vision de la France décarbonée en
2050 ce que vous le savez les besoins
les Français ils ont besoin d'avoir un
cap avec une vision concrète de cette
société en 2050 pour accepter les
contraintes et aussi les nombreux défis
de cette transition nécessaire et pour
aussi donner de l'espoir comme vous
l'avez indiqué donc c'est quoi la France
des carbonées 2050 pour vous merci
merci chers collègues je vais donner la
parole à Frédéric marchand merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur
vasseurman dans votre intervention vous
avez indiqué que l'ADEME devait être
l'accélérateur de la transition
écologique ce à quoi bien évidemment
nous ne pouvons que souscrire et
effectivement cette accélération repose
à la fois sur la capacité opérationnelle
et d'analyse stratégique de l'ADEME
reconnue par toutes et tous sur les
territoires et notamment la semaine
dernière au premier carrefour national
des projets alimentaires territoriaux ou
300 acteurs étaient présents et ont pu
mesurer toute la pertinence du travail
porté aujourd'hui par l'ADEME et au
regard de ce sujet de
rotéritorialisation nos systèmes
alimentaires qui s'inscrit dans le cadre
de notre nécessaire transition
écologique plus de 400 PAP aujourd'hui
quels sont pour vous les moyens
complémentaires supplémentaires pour
faire en sorte que l'ADEME vous parliez
d'ingénierie de défauts parfois
d'ingénierie pour des petites structures
pour que l'ADEME soit le véritable bras
armé de ses beaux dispositifs merci
je vais donner la parole à Jean-Michel
Houlgate
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
vasserman vous avez indiqué que vous
souhaitez que l'ADEME soit le tiers de
confiance qui va éclairer la décision
publique
il s'avère que le 22 mai dernier donc la
première ministre a affirmé que le
gouvernement allait interdire dès 2026
donc l'installation de chaudière à gaz
dans dans l'existence donc vous savez
qui vous avez en ce moment il y a 12
millions de foyers qui ceux qui se
chauffent au gaz dont 5 millions en
maison individuelle et que il y a
également 3 millions cinq logements
collectifs avec des chauffages
individuels donc tout cela va générer à
terme le remplacement de 12 millions de
chauffe de chaudière par par des pompes
à chaleur au fur et à mesure de le
remplacement vous avez été donc
directeur général du réseau gaz de
Strasbourg on a été nous élu alerté
notamment par GRDF qui se pose la
question de la dynamique entre
guillemets du gaz vert qui risque d'être
atteinte par cette décision dont je
voulais savoir comment vous aborder le
sujet et comment apporter je dirais
l'expertise qui est nécessaire pour
éclairer justement cette décision
publique
merci chers collègues je suis dans la
parole Olivier Jacquin merci Président
je vous découvre
vous parlez bien au parlementaire mais
je ne sens pas chez vous le futur
président qui serait indépendant et qui
porterait haut et fort l'ADEME quel que
soit les vents contraires notamment
gouvernementaux et mes questions
porteront sur votre capacité à cette
indépendance et à défendre l'ADEME une
Adam que je connais bien et que
j'apprécie particulièrement ces agents
qui sont bien souvent des militants de
la transition écologique alors je vous
pose deux questions la première comment
outiller la brique intercommunale en
argent en moyen et en ingénierie pour
faire face à la transition écologique et
la deuxième question alors que notre
gouvernement on est vraiment pas
proactif sur ces questions de transition
écologique on le voit encore avec le
rapport du Haut Conseil pour le climat
ou encore le report cette décision
importante sur le financement la
transition écologique aujourd'hui même
comment verriez-vous financer la
transition écologique dans notre pays
c'est une question volontairement de
politique que générale faut-il comme le
proclame Pisani ferries un impôt sur le
grand Patrice sur les grands patrimoine
faut-il une nouvelle taxation des
autoroutes faut-il taxer le kérosène
faut-il un véritable malus au poids sur
les véhicules les plus lourds voilà je
vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est à
Louis Jean de Nicolas
merci monsieur le président
oui merci beaucoup de votre pour votre
intervention et merci d'avoir pensé au
parlementaire dans les dans les réunions
avec les directeurs régionaux c'est de
bonne c'est une bonne idée avant un vote
mais j'espère qu'il sera suivi de ici
j'espère qu'il sera suivi de d'effets
puisque c'est vrai que moi je suis
depuis 2014 au Sénat et j'ai jamais
rencontré le directeur régional de
l'ADEME moi je voulais juste poser une
petite question mais mes collègues l'ont
posé vous avez aussi partiellement
répondu au niveau des intercommunalités
il y a beaucoup de contrats mais il y a
pas de contrat de sobriété comment
réfléchir sur avec les intercommunalités
comment sur un laps de temps qui
pourrait être soit le mandat soit à demi
mandat comment améliorer comment faire
en sorte qu'il y ait des contraintes
sobriété sur le l'énergie parce que au
fond chacun se dit mais c'est pas moi
c'est le voisin qu'il va faire des
efforts moi j'en fais quelques-uns mais
les autres n'en font pas donc c'est pas
la peine que je me fatigue et donc je
crois qu'il y a un vrai travail là
dessus de pédagogie et avec ce que
disait notre collègue Jacquin avec des
outils simples pour pour que ça soit
compréhensible et facile à adopter par
par les les personnes concernées
merci et enfin je vais donner la parole
à Madame varias avant de donner la
parole
est incontestablement un opérateur
public majeur en matière
d'accompagnement de des collectivités
sur cet enjeu qui est la transition
énergétique donc moi bien évidemment ça
va être un peu redondant mais ce qu'on
dit déjà mes collègues mais je confirme
et je mesure la nécessité sur le terrain
que les élus puissent y voir plus clair
entre l'émission de l'ADEME du Serena de
Lana de la NCT
lorsqu'il s'agit de de l'isolation
privée de l'illuration des bâtiments
publics de voilà je pense qu'on se perd
un petit peu dans le magma de tous ces
opérateurs et c'est ce qui revient
beaucoup sur le terrain alors en
Dordogne nous avons eu nous avons
l'ambition de développer un ensemble de
projets d'énergie renouvelable thermique
issue essentiellement de la filière bois
et
deux chaudières ont pu récemment être
installés dans une petite commune grâce
à l'engagement et à la convention
capacée le département avec l'ADEME avec
l'État et encore en partenariat avec le
Syndicat départemental d'électrification
ça a été pour nous une opération
importante qui va se développer sur
d'autres communes que nous avons pu
financer à 80% avec l'aide de la DETR y
compris une fine donc c'est important de
dire ça parce que l'ADEME est perçue
beaucoup comme éloigné des
préoccupations des plus petites communes
il y a cet égard j'aimerais avoir votre
point de vue
moi je reviendrai aussi sur ce qu'a dit
ma collègue face à la à la croissance
exponentielle des des missions de
l'ADEME ne pensez-vous pas que plutôt
mais je crois que vous le pensez plutôt
qu'un recours important la
contractualisation qui s'amplifie ne
faudrait-il pas privilégier des
recrutements pér èdes au sein des
services de l'ADEME et renforcer ses
effectifs alors après j'ai envie de dire
que je le dis pas souvent parce qu'on a
eu beaucoup d'auditions ici qui nous ont
convaincus ou pas mais votre parcours
votre engagement politique auprès votre
engagement d'aller au plus près des des
gélules locaux
l'ensemble de votre de la dynamique que
vous exprimez je vous le dis me donne
envie de vous faire confiance voilà
bien ben voilà une conclusion on est
encore pas voté mais vous avez déjà une
conclusion monsieur le
oui si j'ai bien compris toutes les
questions qui vous sont posées va
falloir que vous soyez en plus un
éclaireur auprès des élus et puis on
nous concitoyens merci de vos réponses
je suis reconnaissant pour ces
nombreuses questions parce que vous
abordez des points qui me donne
l'occasion en tout cas de de partager
mon regard sur le sujet
monsieur le sénateur chevrolier vous
évoquez
l'accompagnement des collectivités la
complexification bon personnellement je
pense que rien ne remplacera de
réfléchir à tout ça vu du point de vue
du maire de vue du point de vue du maire
alors évidemment dans les réseaux qu'on
peut constituer de correspondant indem
il faut probablement segmenter et ça
c'est le travail qu'on peut faire avec
les associations l'association des mers
ruraux de France si elle adhère à cette
logique là d'un point de vue
départemental elle nous aidera à
constituer ce réseau des mers de de
petites communes mais je crois rien ne
remplacera
d'essayer de se dire
pour l'ensemble des acteurs qui
interviennent de se placer dans la
position du maire de voir que finalement
la feuille que je montrais tout à
l'heure c'est pas compréhensible et
qu'il faut pouvoir décrypter même si
c'est encore une fois ces choses sont
des choses de valeur que un maire tout
seul avec ça et je l'ai vécu 1000 fois
mais il a pas la capacité de savoir que
aujourd'hui par exemple le calorifuge
vous êtes maire d'une commune vous
pouvez avoir des calorifuges âge
quasiment gratuite de votre tuyaux et de
vos conduites sauf qu'il faut le savoir
sauf qu'il faut savoir que il y a un
mécanisme avec les certificats d'énergie
qui permettent de s'appuyer sur des
pollueurs qui sont obligés d'investir
etc sauf qu'il faut le savoir faut y
avoir accès il faut pouvoir l'organiser
donc je crois que c'est se placer du
point de vue du maire et de se dire même
si on maîtrise pas tout qu'est-ce qu'on
doit maîtriser du niveau d'un maire
rural du niveau d'un petit PCI et je
crois que c'est ça qui va être
déterminant et quand on parlait des
outils numériques tout à l'heure c'est
comment on essaye d'avoir cette espèce
dont parlait guichet unique aussi tout à
l'heure cette espèce de vue à 360 en
prenant le regard du maire et le faire
avec eux d'ailleurs mais pouvoir dire
voilà moi toute façon je suis mère de
petites communes toute la planète ne
repose pas sur mes épaules mais il y a
des choses concrètes que je peux faire
et oui le calorifugeage de mes tuyaux
qui qui gâchent l'énergie dans le
gymnase et ben je peux avoir une
solution pour les calories réfugiés oui
l'occupation de mes panneaux de mes
toitures ou de telles je peux disposer
voilà c'est une clé de lecture qui ne
soit pas celle du dispositif mais qui
soit celle de l'élu local moi je crois
beaucoup en ça et puis finalement chaque
territoire assez spécificité c'est pas
l'opérateur de le dire à la place de
l'élu bien sûr c'est l'élu qui maîtrise
ça et c'est lui qui a même de faire le
chemin entre des dispositifs qu'on lui
aura décrypté et ceux qui seront
pertinents à mettre en oeuvre sur son
sur son territoire donc c'est le point
important que je voulais signaler sur la
qualité de l'air vous parlez à quelqu'un
qui a vécu ces sujets à Strasbourg parce
que ça a été l'une des villes sur lequel
des problématiques de qualité de l'air
étaient les plus prégnantes alors je
sais pas du tout acteur sur le sujet
c'est bien sûr la collectivité les
grands plans mais
je crois que là en l'occurrence si on
avait plus écouté les injonctions de la
commission plutôt on aurait peut-être
évalué d'en arriver à une situation où
c'était des amendes journalières qui
étaient en jeu alors c'est des sujets
complexes j'en suis conscient j'avais
écrit lorsque j'étais étudiant c'est
étudiant à l'ENA un mémoire sur la
qualité de l'air et sur l'impact sur la
santé publique pour essayer de démontrer
dans le Bas-Rhin il y a un sujet sur les
durées de vie et sur l'impact de
l'environnement sur la durée de vie
c'est multifactorielle c'est compliqué
mais
j'avais j'avais vu le sujet de l'air
intérieur et de l'air extérieur
j'insiste sur l'air intérieur parce
qu'on a toujours tendance à penser que
le problème n'est que l'extérieur mais
on a beaucoup progressé notamment sur
les formes aldéhydes et tous ces sujets
donc je n'ai que je n'ai pas
d'expertise majeure sur le sujet juste
une expertise d'études et une expertise
pratique sur la vision 2050
quelle est la vision concrète du monde
de demain en 2050 et du monde dans une
logique de développement durable je
crois que là on est vraiment sur sur en
tout cas la parole que je propose portée
si vous me faites confiance c'est cette
parole d'action et d'espoir parce que
les solutions existent encore faut-il de
façon efficace
méthodique comme on disait tout à
l'heure
pouvoir les mettre en oeuvre et
expérimenter les nouvelles solutions qui
existent monsieur le sénateur marchand
vous parliez de
la logique opérationnelle notamment sur
des Pat
alors ce que j'aimerais dire quel serait
le rôle de l'ADEME sur le
là où ça marche ça marche très bien les
pattes donc c'est vraiment un outil un
outil important moi je crois qu'il y a
un au-delà des subventions qui existent
aujourd'hui je crois que ça prend un
million d'euros que donne la dame
au-delà de ça je crois qu'il y a une
fonction que moi j'appelle laisser mage
alors pourquoi laisser mal les bonnes il
suffit pas de enfin je l'ai vécu 1000
fois en tant que local il suffit pas de
partager les bonnes pratiques pour que
ça marche et pour que ça se diffuse vous
avez plein parlé plein de livrets des
bonnes pratiques très bien vous lisez ça
ça vous mais ça suffit pas laissé mage
pour moi c'est identifier les bonnes
pratiques essayez de les modéliser entre
guillemets de les porter sur d'autres
territoires qui sont susceptibles
d'avoir où elles sont susceptibles de
fonctionner et de travailler avec les
élus territoriaux pour voir si cette
bonne pratique peut être dupliquée peut
être adaptée peut être transposée cette
fonction décimage là pour le coup vu que
l'ADEME a des experts extrêmement
pointus dans le domaine et en prise
directe avec tous les territoires là je
pense qu'il y a une fonction de que
j'appelle smash serait peut-être un peu
trop long monsieur le Président pour
pour élaborer sur le sujet mais à votre
disposition pour en parler monsieur le
sénateur Houlgate
on parlait du tiers de confiance on
parlait du gaz et de GrDF alors
évidemment c'est le monde du gaz j'en
viens j'ai vécu aussi la transformation
de ce de
ce monde comme je le disais tout à
l'heure notamment avec le biométhane
à l'époque chez RDF était sur une
logique de dire il faut que 30% de notre
notre réseau soit soit alimenté par du
gaz vert et du biométhane
sur les thématiques de biométhane on est
aujourd'hui on en est loin de ces 30%,
je crois il y a aussi des sujets de
d'hydrogène qu'on peut injecter mais ce
que je voudrais dire simplement
c'est pas moi qui vais décider et c'est
pas le président de l'ADEME qui décide
si vous confiez cette responsabilité qui
décide du mix énergétique en France cela
dit cela dit on a des actifs et le
réseau la capillarité du réseau de gaz
est un actif important et je crois que
la vraie question c'est comment on fait
en sorte que cette actif soit valorisée
que ce soit avec des injections
d'hydrogène que soit avec des injections
massives de gaz vert j'ai vu dans le
grand test et la réalisation leader en
biométhane aujourd'hui la difficulté
j'avais vécu à l'époque trois projets de
biométhane un avaient échoué pour cause
d'acceptabilité citoyenne
parce que les gens avaient manifesté
contre le projet qui qui dégradait le
paysage et ils avaient très peur des
intrants qu'on y mettrait et deux qui
ont réussi et il y avait à peu près 400
projets à l'époque il y en a à peu près
la moitié qui ont abouti j'attire votre
attention sur le fait que ces projets de
biométhane mettent deux fois plus deux
fois plus longtemps que à réaliser qu'en
Allemagne et qu'ils aboutissent une fois
sur qu'ils aboutissent deux fois moins
donc je pense qu'on a des sujets aussi
dans la façon alors le législateur a
fait évoluer beaucoup de choses
positivement mais il faut qu'on en soit
conscient on ne peut pas se permettre
d'être deux fois plus long pour un
porteur de projets agriculteurs ou élus
local d'un projet de biométhane d'être
deux fois plus long que de l'autre côté
du rein alors je pensais exemple parce
que voilà parce que j'habite tout près
de la frontière et que je connais et
qu'on échange avec les collègues
également mais voilà il faut qu'on
arrive à s'inspirer sur ces bonnes
pratiques-là le législateur a beaucoup
amélioré la situation depuis donc voilà
sur l'avenir du gaz je pense que il ne
faut il faut trouver les bonnes
solutions pour valoriser cette actif et
moi je crois que le le biométhane et
l'hydrogène sont des éléments à vraiment
considérés
sur l'indépendance monsieur le sénateur
Jacquier
ça je crois que je ne pourrai pas vous
convaincre avec mes mots
et c'est mon parcours qui plaidera pour
moi échanger avec les gens avec qui j'ai
travaillé pour savoir si j'ai une
éthique une posture le courage aussi de
de faire mes choix de les faire en
indépendance et de faire ce que je pense
est juste j'ai l'impression que tous les
toutes les expériences de la vie j'ai pu
avoir j'ai eu la chance d'avoir dans mon
parcours sont aujourd'hui arrivés au
point où je pense qu'elles prennent sens
on regarde la responsabilité à laquelle
je postule après mon parcours mon
éthique c'est pas moi qui vais pouvoir
vous convaincre au travers de quelques
phrases mais je vous invite à échanger
avec ceux avec qui j'ai pu travailler
dans ma vie ceux avec qui j'ai pu
échanger parce que c'est une éthique
personnelle dont évidemment que
j'apporterai avec moi et que je voudrais
je voudrais poursuivre je suis conscient
de cette indépendance et lorsque je dis
la dame tiers de confiance c'est ça que
je veux mettre en oeuvre c'est ça que je
veux mettre en oeuvre quand la presse
fait un gros tit sur le président de
l'ADEME et pour ou contre le nucléaire
ça part du postulat que l'opinion
personnelle sur telle ou tel sujet je
prends le nucléaire ça peut être le le
gaz que l'opinion personnelle du
président va impacter les études que la
dame va fournir au décideurs publics non
il faut une intégrité intellectuelle ce
que vous appelez indépendance en tout
cas une honnêteté intellectuelle dans
les analyses qui sont faites et en tout
cas moi je ne pourrais pas vous
convaincre et c'est plus mon parcours et
mon éthique personnel qui j'espère
pourront le faire si vous échangez avec
avec des gens qui m'ont côtoyé
je voudrais enfin répondre sur le point
de de d'outils simples et de la façon
dont on peut travailler sur la sobriété
au niveau local et vous m'interrogiez
sur vous espérez que mon engagement sur
les Dr vis-à-vis des parlementaires
soient respectés mais moi ce que je vous
propose monsieur le Président si vous me
confiez cette responsabilité c'est que
je sois là dans un an
bien sûr mais au milieu au plus tard
dans un an que je vous interroge et que
je vous pose la question et j'aurai avec
moi parce que ce sera pas une option
pour les directeurs régionaux de
contacter et d'organiser ces sessions
assez approfondie de
rencontres avec les parlementaires et
j'aurais avec moi en tout cas c'est
l'engagement que je prends c'est pas une
idée c'est un engagement j'aurais avec
moi toutes les réunions les dates les la
réalité de ces réunions en tout cas je
pense que ce chaînon manquant est
préjudiciable parce que comme vous
l'avez tous dit les liens entre l'ADEME
et les parlementaires et on parlait
d'indépendance monsieur le sénateur le
lien qu'on construira avec le Parlement
il est essentiel il est bien sûr
essentiel ici à Paris mais il est
essentiel aussi sur les territoires
et et et la raison pour laquelle je
pense que ces réunions sont importantes
c'est pas uniquement pour vous faire
plaisir et parce que je suis persuadé
que c'est par ce lien là que les
parlementaires enrichiront les textes de
loi qui le porteront décideront mieux
des budgets qu'ils auront et que c'est
le chaînon manquant aujourd'hui sur ce
sujet là et c'est pour ça qu'au travers
de votre vote je pense aujourd'hui bien
sûr je souhaite être élu vous aurez
compris ma motivation pour cette pour
cette belle mission mais je crois qu'il
y a aussi un message que ma candidature
n'est pas partisane et que mon parcours
quand j'ai été vice-président de
l'Assemblée par exemple la démontrer que
la seule loi que j'ai écrite est portée
dont j'ai été le rapporteur a été voté
en première lecture à l'Assemblée à
l'unanimité voilà donc cette logique de
dire on doit créer ce chaînon manquant
on doit solidifier on doit en toute
transparence avec nos nos problèmes avec
nos enjeux de recrutement évidemment
quand je dis que la richesse numéro 1 de
la dame c'est les femmes et les hommes
qui travaillent c'est pas pour dire
qu'on peut prendre des intérimaires
pendant trois semaines pour combler un
vide c'est pas possible c'est pas c'est
pas comme ça qu'on peut construire des
relations de confiance donc je crois que
ce lien il est tout autant utile à vous
qu'il l'est à la dame pour vous puissiez
être les
va me permettre de le dire les avocats
au sein au sein du Parlement au sein de
la puissance publique de l'efficacité et
de la compétence que les femmes et les
hommes de l'ADEME apportent au quotidien
au territoire voilà j'espère avoir
répondu madame varias peut-être pour
conclure d'abord vous remercier pour vos
pour vos mots
je pense avoir répondu à l'ensemble des
points notamment que vous avez pu
mentionner
l'exemple était extrêmement parlant sur
sur les les aides de l'ADEME
privilégiez le recrutement j'en ai
vraiment parlé et le côté pérenne et
conclure donc on vous remercions pour
pour les paroles que vous avez prononcé
à mon endroit je vous remercie merci on
va on va libérer le candidat
mes chers collègues je vais Martin de
Sidrac rapporteur va vous appeler dans
l'ordre alphabétique et vous irez voté
là-bas et moi pendant ce temps là je
raccompagne le candidat merci pour votre
prestation merci pour vos explications